In this post-Endgame world, the Thor series
is breaking new ground for Marvel as The Odinson
becomes the first hero to be granted four
solo films.
Thanks to a ton of new details spewing from
the hype factory that is San Diego Comic-Con,
we know a little more about what to expect
from the upcoming Thor 4.
If you're a little behind on your Thor lore,
let's get you up to speed.
In 2017, under the direction of Taika Waititi,
Ragnarok sprung into theaters.
The movie chronicled Thor's attempts to save
Asgard from his conniving and powerful sister
Hela — along with his struggle to escape
from the garbage planet Sakaar with Loki and
Bruce Banner.
By introducing new characters like Valkyrie
— along with everybody's favorite alien
bros Korg and Miek …
"Hey man.
I'm Korg.
This is Miek.
We're gonna jump on that spaceship and get
outta here.
Wanna come?"
… and injecting a much-needed dose of whimsy
into the Thor series, Ragnarok became a welcome
addition to the MCU, receiving rave reviews
and crushing the box office.
Ragnarok finds Thor learning to accept that,
as Odin and Heimdall said …
"Asgard is not a place — it's a people."
Recognizing that the only way to save his
home is to let it be destroyed, he finally
takes his place as king as he shepherds his
citizens into space, charting a course for
a new home on Earth.
Tragically, that's where Thanos comes in,
leaving half of the Asgardian refugees dead
in his quest for the Infinity Stones as Avengers:
Infinity War begins.
A devastated Thor survives Thanos' final snap,
leaving him to spend Endgame seeking justice
and revenge for those he's lost.
When Thanos is at last defeated, Thor is one
of the only original Avengers left standing.
Ultimately, he ends up joining the Guardians
of the Galaxy to fight evil throughout the
universe, leaving his right-hand woman, Valkyrie,
in charge of the recently-founded Norwegian
territory of New Asgard.
All of this has set the stage for what's to
come in the next Thor movie.
After the success of Thor: Ragnarok, it makes
sense that Marvel would want director Taika
Waititi to return for Thor 4, considering
the acclaim that Waititi's irreverent and
dry comedic sensibilities garnered for Ragnarok.
By taking one of Marvel's most serious and
austere superheroes and making him and his
surrounding cast totally accessible and even
fun, Waititi immediately left a mark on the
franchise and made himself indispensable as
a fresh voice in the MCU.
"This one time when we were children, he transformed
himself into a snake and he knows that I love
snakes, so then I went to pick up the snake
to admire it, and he transformed back into
himself and went 'MYEH!
It's me!'
Even though Marvel fans are likely thrilled
that Waititi is officially confirmed to return
for the fourth Thor film, it does get in the
way of one of his other long-awaited projects.
Waititi is placing his adaptation of the cyberpunk
anime classic Akira on hold so that he can
return to the MCU, despite the fact that the
project had recently been fast-tracked by
Warner Bros.
Fans can only hope that Waititi will be able
to revive Akira after he completes Thor 4,
but it's still clear that the filmmaker is
giving up plenty of opportunities to make
sure he can return to the Marvel cosmos.
It's usually a safe bet that Marvel will have
a strong showing at San Diego Comic-Con, and
in 2019, as the studio looked forward post-Phase
3, there was plenty of breaking news about
upcoming Marvel projects, including Thor's
next outing.
During the huge Marvel panel on Saturday,
July 20th at SDCC, cast members — along
with Waititi himself — made an appearance
to make a few major announcements about Thor
4.
First off, the film's official title will
be Thor: Love and Thunder, which could give
us some indication about the film's tone as
well as tell us a little about what lies in
store for Thor himself — maybe the hero
will be able to find a little time for romance
between fights with various bad guys.
As far as the release date goes, Thor: Love
and Thunder will hit theaters on November
5th, 2021, serving as the finale of the MCU's
Phase 4.
A fourth Thor movie likely wouldn't have even
gotten a greenlight if Chris Hemsworth hadn't
hopped back on board to play what has now
become his signature role, so it's not surprising
that he is expected to return as the God of
Thunder.
Though Hemsworth's Thor was a bit too serious
in the earlier films, Ragnarok and Endgame
both saw a sillier side of the superhero.
In Ragnarok, during his time as a captive
of Jeff Goldblum's ridiculous Grandmaster,
he ends up slated to fight the Hulk, leading
to one of the film's most infamous lines.
"Hey!
Hey!
We know each other!
He's a friend from work!"
Even as he tries to save his ancestral home
from Hela's clutches, he maintains a healthy
sense of humor.
Endgame sees Thor returning to his serious
roots as he mourns the victims of Thanos,
but he still gets plenty of comedic moments
when his fellow Avengers discover "Bro Thor"
five years after the team parts ways.
"No, no — give me that."
“You have the little one."
Serving as an unexpectedly comedic presence
in such a heavy film, Hemsworth anchors his
emotional beats while still keeping his performance
light and entertaining, proving that he's
more than capable of playing Thor in Love
and Thunder and for years to come.
"Are you crying?"
"No….. yes."
Quite a few familiar faces will return for
Thor: Love and Thunder, including one Oscar
winner who's been absent from the film series
for a while now.
In an unsurprising bit of news that was also
announced at SDCC, Tessa Thompson will return
to play the fierce, swaggering Valkyrie, who's
currently handling matters in New Asgard during
Thor's post-Endgame jaunt with the Guardians
of the Galaxy.
Thompson and head Marvel honcho Kevin Feige
also made it clear that the movie would confirm
Valkyrie's bisexuality, noting that she needs
to "find her queen," making for a landmark
in representation and diversity in this multi-franchise
universe.
However, the most exciting casting announcement
was undoubtedly that Natalie Portman, who
played Thor's love interest Jane in both Thor
and Thor: The Dark World, will return to the
franchise and pick up Mjolnir herself as a
new Thor — just as the character did in
a recent comics run from writer Jason Aaron.
As Portman took the stage and held Mjolnir
high to celebrate this thrilling development,
she quipped, quote, "I've always had a little
hammer envy."
The talented actress' return to the world
of Thor would have been big enough news, but
letting Portman become a superhero in her
own right just ups the ante.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.